I lie down his leash Vic hello everyone
and welcome to my very first video for
you my name is fetus on shotta I've been
living in Berlin for two and a half
years and I come from Syria firoz a
shatter creates videos and posts them on
the internet there about how he sees the
Germans he lives among the series is
titled sukin which means sugar Zuka I
Stein [ __ ] filali looted it's easy for
anyone in Germany whether a German a
refugee a foreigner anyone who's
interested and to watch our videos and
have a good laugh we just opened Latin
this video documents an experiment he
took up position blindfolded in the
heart of Berlin the sign next to him
says I am a Syrian refugee I trust you
do you trust me hug me he stood there
and waited and waited
you
my brow key food you need to have the
feeling that Germans want to have
something to do with the refugees that
they can trust them so when somebody
comes up and hugs you that's a great
feeling that somebody trusts you off
with olives feta says that in Syria he
helped organize demonstrations against
president bashar al-assad and was jailed
and tortured for doing so after his
release he continued to shoot videos of
what was going on he came to Germany in
2013 to work on a film project and then
applied for asylum that's the taisigi my
very first day here the carnival of
cultures festival was under way it was
quite a surprise oh I thought oh my god
what is this a carnival I never seen
anything like it in my life everyone was
drunk there was lots of naked skin it
was all new to me it took a while to get
used to it all and habitat get our
quistis except dear who is mean
fetus feels good here now his relaxed
approach to the fraud issue of cultural
integration resonates with many his
videos on social media have been viewed
more than 2 million times though at
first he only posted one on his personal
facebook page he and his team want to
build on his success and produce more
films we hadn't fought via physician Mia
Luther to LA we definitely want to make
more people laugh and we want to
continue to examine life in Germany from
our perspective buses much to show what
we do and how I see Germany in mine
alguns here its opulent I've learned
that Germans need a bit of time but then
they can't be stopped that's why i
believe integration will be a success
eventually Linda bye-bye